oui
qu'est ce que l'europe change dans nos
vies environnement économie santé sur
tous ces sujets l'europe et nous part à
la rencontre des citoyens pour
comprendre quels impacts à l'union
européenne sur notre quotidien
l'europe et nous c'est tous les mardis
18h35 sur public sénat pas ça nous
chaque semaine durant 45 minutes sur
public sénat c'est un homme ou une femme
politique et qui se prête au jeu servait
le plus réactif possible des questions
réponses avec moi sur le plateau
plusieurs journalistes de la presse
écrite pour relancer l'invité allait
bien sûr au fond des dossiers mais
également aller chercher la petite phase
il s'agit d'animer le débat vip et passe
à nous présenter par michel grossiord
c'est tous les mardis en direct à 18h45
sur public sénat
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sauna pour la
traditionnelle la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement comme un
jeudi sur deux le sénat interroge
interpellent le gouvernement et les
ministres sur des thèmes d'actualité et
aujourd'hui évidemment c'est la crise
économique et ses conséquences sociales
ses conséquences en matière d'emploi et
bien sûr la grande grève aujourd'hui qui
va bien sûr mobiliser l'essentiel de
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement par moins de quatre
questions autour de cette crise
économique de question également sur le
bouclier fiscal
une autre sur les déficits et les
prélèvements obligatoires faut-il ou non
augmenter les impôts voyez donc une
prime en une prédominance économique et
social cet après midi au sénat
je vous laisse tout de suite écoutez
elle les sénateurs dans l'hémicycle en
appel questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que là où le ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente et je demande à chacune et à
chacun de bien respecter ce temps je
vais donner la parole à monsieur hervé
maurey pour le groupe union centriste
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
budget des comptes publics et de la
fonction publique
monsieur le ministre depuis quelques
jours la question de l'augmentation des
prélèvements obligatoires fait débat au
sein même de la majorité
nous l'avons vu ce matin même à
l'assemblée nationale et nous le verrons
très certainement prochainement ici
certaines personnalités suggère en effet
de supprimer ou en tout cas de modifier
le bouclier fiscal
d'autres de créer ce qui s'est fait aux
états unis un prélèvement supplémentaire
sur les très hauts revenus
un amendement en ce sens a été adoptée
hier par la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale
ces prises de positions résulte bien
entendu de la dégradation des déficits
publics du fait de la crise économique
je rappelle que le projet de loi de
finances rectificative dont nous aurons
prochainement à débattre portera à 104
milliards d'euros le déficit budgétaire
et le total des déficit public à 5,6
pour cent du pib
le projet de loi de finances initiale se
baser sur 52 milliards d'euros de
déficit budgétaire c'est-à-dire deux
fois - et sur un déficit public de 3,1
pour cent du pib
c'était il y a 6 mois ces initiatives
répond également un souci d'équité et de
justice fiscale parce qu'il n'est pas
anormal de penser que dans des périodes
telles que celles que l'on connaît
actuellement un effort de solidarité
supplémentaire peut être demander à ceux
qui en ont les moyens le président de la
république a pour sa part déclaré qu'il
n'avait pas été élu pour augmenter les
impôts et il a raison je souscris
pleinement à cette affirmation
compte tenu du poids trop élevé des
prélèvements obligatoires dans notre
pays et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que
j'avais émis quelques réserves
lorsque nous avons créé il ya quelques
mois seulement une nouvelle taxe pour
financer le rsa
cependant les circonstances
exceptionnelles que nous connaissons
actuellement pourrait me semble-t-il
justifier des mesures exceptionnelles à
condition naturellement qu'elle soit
provisoire alors ma question monsieur le
ministre est très simple dès lors que le
gouvernement n'envisage pas d'augmenter
les impôts ni de réduire les déductions
fiscales
comment envisage-t-il de maîtriser et a
fortiori de réduire les déficits
sachant que la réduction des déficits et
de la dette était aussi un engagement de
la campagne présidentielle de nicolas
sarkozy
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur andré santini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la fonction
publique vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs ou sur le sénateur mots
rei je voudrais tout d'abord excusé eric
woerth qui est retenue et à l'assemblée
nationale dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances rectificatif le niveau des
déficits traduit effectivement la
gravité de la situation mais il faut
bien voir que nous sommes confrontés à
la fois un déficit de crise et un
déficit structurel
il faut donc s'assurer d'une part que le
déficit dû à la crise reste bien
temporaire et d'autre part poursuivre
les réformes pour parvenir à réduire le
déficit structurel
on ne peut pas même face à une crise
cette ampleur mettre en péril la
soutenabilité à moyen terme de nos
finances publiques
mais il ne faut pas se tromper deux
solutions augmenter les impôts n'est pas
une solution
lorsqu'on commence à augmenter les
impôts des plus aisés
il n'est pas loin le temps où on
augmentera les impôts de tous en cette
période la justice je suis heureux je
suis heureux 2-2 réjouir la gauche de
l'assemblée qui a enfin trouvé une
occasion de parader en cette période la
justice et l'efficacité me semble mieux
servis par une baisse des prélèvements
sur les plus modestes que par une
sanction sur les plus riches
quand ton bouclier fiscal nous avons eu
ce débat légitime il ya 18 mois un
bouclier jeu sénateurs à 50%
c'est tout simplement juste est-il
interdit de réussir en france si lens à
gauche
la réussite matérielle doit-elle rimer
avec expatriation décourager l'effort et
le travail ne peut pas être une solution
la clé c'est d'agir sur la dépense pour
les dépenses visant à lutter contre la
crise
nous avons mis en place un plan de
relance rapide temporaire ciblées sur
l'investissement ces dépenses ne dégrade
pas l'actif net de la france et sont
réversibles
parallèlement nous conservons une ferme
maîtrise des dépenses courantes
nous poursuivons donc la rgpp et
l'ensemble des réformes structurelles
nous avons aussi fait des avancées
majeures sur le contrôle des niches
fiscales et sociales
nous avons inscrit une croissance des
dépenses dans la loi de programmation
des finances publiques deux fois plus
faible que celle connue en moyenne par
le passé une relance efficace ciblé
temporaire préparant l'avenir une
maîtrise sans précédent des dépenses
courantes voilà monsieur le sénateur
comment nous pourrons sortir de la crise
plus forts que nous y sommes entrés chez
monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant monsieur françois marque pour
le groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'économie et des finances
et porte sur le véritable scandale que
constitue aujourd'hui le bouclier fiscal
notre notre pays traverse une grave
crise financière économique et sociale
aujourd'hui particulièrement le peuple
de notre pays gronder je me permets à
cet instant d'excusés nombre de nos
collègues qui sont aux côtés des
manifestants qui par millions les fils
en france ne nous dit pas ne nous dites
pas que les protestations sont le fruit
d'une mauvaise information sur la
situation les français ça veut faire la
part des choses ils savent très bien
faire la différence entre ce dont vous
êtes comptable et ceux dont vous n'avez
pas la maîtrise et ces français que
voit-il aujourd'hui ils voient que la
majorité d'entre eux connaissent de plus
en plus de difficulté difficultés
d'emploi de pouvoir d'achat de logement
d'éducation de santé
en même temps les français voient que
des entreprises pas tout certes luan la
verse de gros dividendes tout en
licenciant que des dirigeants
d'entreprises touche des rémunérations
indécentes et que le gouvernement auquel
vous appartenez ne cesse de protéger les
plus aisés et d'alléger le poids des
contributions dont ils sont redevables
envers la communauté nationale
ainsi alors que le déficit budgétaire
2009 va battre tous les records avec 104
milliards prévus à ce jour alors que le
premier ministre annonce que les caisses
sont vides
ce gouvernement trouve néanmoins
l'argent nécessaire pour envoyer 834
chèques d'un montant moyen de 368 1000
euros excusez du peu
à des contribuables très aisés ce
véritable scandale du bouclier fiscal
illustre à lui seul la déraison de la
politique fiscale de ce gouvernement les
impôts des plus modestes servent à faire
des chèques aux plus riches
on est on est très loin des grands
principes de la république mes chers
collègues et en réclamant la suppression
du bouclier fiscal non à juste raison
que l'on mette fin à ce dévoiement de la
république madame la ministre citant de
voix s'élèvent aujourd'hui contre le
bouclier fiscal ce n'est pas uniquement
pour une question de morale républicaine
c'est aussi parce que le souci de lutter
efficacement contre la crise et de
mobiliser tous les français à cette fin
notre question nécessite de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur une vraie solidarité une
solidarité bien comprise condition
première de l'efficacité politique j'en
viens à ma question monsieur président
oui les gouvernements britannique et
américain ont bien compris le sujet en
annonçant de prochaines hausses d'impôts
pour les plus aisés
alors madame la ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres
le bouclier fiscal est injuste le
bouclier fiscal est antirépublicain
quand allez-vous supprimer le bouclier
fiscal
sa parole et à monsieur andré santini
or deux minutes
jouer comme je vois que le sujet
passionne surtout les bons puisque nous
aurons une troisième question tout à
l'heure et je vais essayer de ne pas
trop répétitif pour ne pas vous lasser
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs ou sur le sénateur mark un
bouclier à 50%
c'est tout simplement juste qui peut
dire le contraire c'est même une règle
de valeur constitutionnelle
chez plusieurs de nos voisins il s'agit
d'éviter qu'on travaille plus d'un jour
sur deux pour l'état en phase osta la
majorité a bien veillé grâce au
plafonnement des riches des niches
fiscales à ce qu'un contribuable ne
puisse plus s'exonérer de l'impôt en
cumulant les avantages fiscaux
le bouclier fiscal de 2008 mesurer au 12
février 2009 dernières dates dont j'ai
les chiffres c'est 458 millions d'euros
soit 7 milliards 7 lié à la loi dite
tepa entend donc bien le bouclier fiscal
c'est 6% du total liées à la loi tepa
pas plus la loi était pas c'est d'abord
des mesures pour le plus grand nombre
à commencer par les heures
supplémentaires qui concerne tout le
monde
à la vérité pouvons nous trouver ce
débat un peu contre productif gagner de
l'argent en france et il illégitime à
questions directes réponse directe non
bien sûr que non et nous nous étonnions
que vous la pose y est en ces termes
monsieur le sénateur serions nous
perverti au point de dénigrer ceux qui
réussissent seriez vous prêt à montrer
du doigt les chefs d'entreprise de votre
circonscription qui réussissent qui ont
décidé d'y investir d'y créer des
richesses et de l'emploi
plafonner la pression fiscale mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs ses limites et
le départ des français vers des pays
dans la fiscalité est moins élevé il
s'agit d'une mesure de productivité nous
croyons qu'il faut cesser
la politique politicienne la démagogie
disons le pour en convenir tous ensemble
il y avait dans ce pays deux offense à
la justice fiscale
2 péché contre l'esprit le premier set
est qu'on puisse payer plus de 50% de
son revenu
parfois même 100 % ou plus en impôts
annuels le second celui contre lequel
personne n'avait trouvé de solution
avant cette législature c'est que la
multiplication et le déplafonnement de
certaines niches fiscales permettaient à
des contres et blanc de s'exonérer
complètement d'impôt sur le revenu
nous y avons mis fin nous l'avons su
conclure monsieur le ministre pour
l'absolution nous le revendiquons cette
vérité là nous aimerions que tout le
monde s'attachent à la rappeler la
parole est maintenant monsieur bernard
véra pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen sénateurs du parti
de gauche avaient la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre je tiens
tout d'abord à saluer le mouvement
social puissant et rassembleur qui se
déroule aujourd'hui se traduit par de
nombreuses manifestations réunissant
plusieurs millions de salariés soutenus
par 80 % de l'opinion publique
la plupart des sénatrices et des
sénateurs de notre groupe sont
d'ailleurs présents dans ces
manifestations
ce mouvement est le signe évident de
l'inquiétude et de la colère de la
france qui travaille et qui crée des
richesses
un signe qui appelle d'autres réponses
que les mesurettes fort limitée
annoncées par le gouvernement
il participe aussi après les succès des
mouvements revendicatifs de l'outre-mer
d'une profonde et large aspiration à
trouver dans la situation de crise
d'autres sites solution que la litanie
des plans de licenciement ou le
développement du chômage partiel et le
blocage des salaires et des pensions
cette aspiration de justice sociale
est si forte qu'elle vont indécente
l'existence du bouclier fiscal comme
celle des rémunérations et bonus
exorbitants des patrons du cac 40 et des
plus grandes entreprises
le bouclier fiscal est bel et bien un
cadeau éhonté destiné à une infime
minorité de privilégiés au moment où la
grande majorité du peuple de notre pays
doit se serrer la ceinture si le
ministère des finances
ose prétendre que les deux tiers des
quatorze mille bénéficiaires du bouclier
fiscal sont de condition modeste
c'est pour mieux masquer que 834 ménages
fortunés ont obtenu du trésor public
plus de trois cent soixante huit mille
euros de remboursement en 2008 soit 300
années de smic par contribuable au total
le bouclier fiscal coûte 450 8 millions
d'euros
c'est plus que les crédits de la
rénovation urbaine et que les aides
versées par le ministère de la jeunesse
et des sports affirmé que le bouclier
fiscal a favorisé le retour des émigrés
fiscaux
votre relation j'y viens monsieur le
président les parlementaires de mon
groupe soucieux de l' équilibre des
deniers publics et de la justice fiscale
ont déposé le 15 octobre dernier une
proposition de loi tendant à abroger le
bouclier fiscal le 26 mars prochain ce
texte inscrit à l'ordre du jour du sénat
mais la majorité de droite semblent
décidés à empêcher son adoption alors
tout en regrettant l'absence de monsieur
le premier ministre
comme celle des ministres concernés ma
question est simple
le gouvernement va-t-il enfin entendre
le peuple
allez-vous supprimer cette disposition
inique apurer vous notre proposition
d'abrogation du bouclier fiscal en débat
le 26 mars
la parole est à monsieur andré santini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la fonction
publique de la part aussi monsieur le
ministre on connaissait le buisson
n'avait pas le taire alors monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur verra je
risque d'ailleurs de représenter le
gouvernement le jour du dépôt de la
proposition de loi
alors bien sûr je vais répondre
il n'est donc pas juste monsieur le
sénateur de stigmatiser les
bénéficiaires du bouclier fiscal
ce sont les personnes qui ont un
remboursement total de 458 millions
d'euros qui avait préalablement payé
plus de un milliard cent d'euros
d'impôts c'est parce qu'il versait
souvent oui je vois que votre coeur
demeure inaccessible à ce genre de
détresse mais il faut quand même que les
chiffres vous soit cité il versait plus
de 80% voire 100 % de leurs revenus aux
impôts et leurs contributions été ramené
à 50 % l'impôt le sénateur est une
affaire de citoyenneté non de
confiscation vous avez un peut invoquer
la justice est-il juste de payer plus de
50% de ses revenus en impôts
est-il juste de travailler plus d'un
jour sur deux pour l'état cette
situation n'existe nulle part ailleurs
la coexistence d'un impôt en france sur
le revenu élevé et d'un impôt sur le
patrimoine également élevé impose de
plafonner la pression fiscale d'où
l'instauration du bouclier fiscal qui
est un système juste la véritable
injustice cette experte un contribuable
plus s'exonérer de l'impôt à travers
l'utilisation excessive davantage
fiscaux par le recours aux niches
fiscales
nous avons donc décidé de les plafonner
enfin monsieur le sénateur on n'est pas
en france un voleur lorsqu'on gagne de
l'argent parce qu'on a réussi
si l'on veut faire partir de france
toute sa richesse
alors il faut prendre les mesures que
vous préconisez à une époque de très
grande mobilité du capital et de confier
voulait confirmer nice notamment autres
pays européens
surtaxer abouti en réalité à des taxes
et ce coup de frein au départ c'est la
première fois depuis 2000 qu'on observe
puisqu'en 2007 les départs du territoire
ont baissé de 15% et les retours
augmenté de 10%
ce n'est pas un hasard si c'est la
première année de mise en oeuvre du
bouclier fiscal
merci monsieur le ministre a parlé
maintenant président hors hydra cours
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je suis un peu désolé parce
que ma question s'adressant au ministre
de l'agriculture elle va se situer sur
un autre registre par rapport à celui
que nous avons en chantonnay il y à
quelques depuis le début de la séance
c'est une question agricole et c'est
donc monsieur karoutchi qui développera
la politique agricole du gouvernement
dans quelques instants je voulais en
effet
dire au ministre de l'agriculture qui
l'a présenté il ya peu de temps les
modalités de mise en oeuvre du bilan de
santé de la politique agricole commune
au terme d'une d'ailleurs très longue
concertation près d'un milliard 4
d'euros dettes directes reçues par les
agriculteurs seront réorientés en 2010
pour d'une part consolider l'économie et
l'emploi dans les territoires soutenir
l'élevage à l'herbe prévoir un
développement durable et instaurer la
gestion des rixes des risques la
profession sait bien qu'il est
indispensable d'adapter la politique
agricole commune dans la perspective de
2013 mais en abordant le financement des
quatre objectifs que je viens de
rappeler on s'aperçoit que les
prélèvements de solidarité sur les
cultures végétales en particulier risque
de créer de vraies difficultés à ce qu
on appelle les zones intermédiaires qui
ont des rendements moyens sur des sols
relativement médiocre et avec des
exploitations le plus souvent elle même
de taille moyenne
les conséquences pourraient conduire à
supprimer ces soutiens indispensables à
la survie de nombreuses exploitations
qui pourraient ainsi perdre jusqu'à 80
euros l'hectare et j'ai trois questions
à vous poser monsieur le ministre
comment faire évoluer ce système pour
qu'il prenne en compte la diversité de
nos régions assure anne aux céréaliers
quelle que soit la région
la juste rétribution de leur travail
pourrait-on envisager une mise en
application progressive sur 2010-2013
des mesures qui ont été prises et
pourrait-on accompagner financièrement
les exploitations de type spécialisés
ou polyculture élevage ayant des
surfaces consacrées aux productions
végétales qui s'engageraient sur des
axes de développement de la biodiversité
ou bien de réduction de la dépendance
énergétique grâce à des choix culture au
maître monsieur roger karoutchi
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement
j'avais la peur c'est monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président un coup je voudrais d'abord
excusé si vous le voulez bien l'absence
de michel barnier qui ont eu le bonheur
et plaisir à vous répondre mais il est
aujourd'hui à bruxelles en négociation
justement sur la pac
monsieur le président de raincourt vous
avez exprimé plusieurs inquiétudes
auxquelles le gouvernement est très
sensible premier point malheureusement
et vous le savez nous ne pouvons pas
pour le milliard 4 dead envisagée nous
ne pouvons pas le faire de manière
progressive
là la réorientation ce froid sur les
aides payés en décembre 2010 c'est un
accord européen là-dessus nous n'avons
pas liberté pleine et entière mais nous
avons compris et le ministre de
l'agriculture est très attentif à la
situation des départements ou des
secteurs que l'on pourrait qualifier
d'intermédiaire et qui sont en réalité
les secteurs les plus en difficulté par
rapport au rééquilibrage et à la
réorientation michel barnier a mises en
débat dans le cadre des groupes de
travail
la situation des territoires
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire de ceux qui
ont des revenus ou des niveaux de
soutien partagé entre et plus faibles
que ceux des territoires à fort
potentiel est plus fort que ceux de zone
en vraie difficulté
donc ce sont ces territoires
intermédiaire que le plus de problèmes
par rapport à la réorientation des aides
diverses voies ont été ouvertes et sont
à l'étude
le ministre annoncera début avril un
certain nombre de mesures dans les
diverses voies la réattribution
prioritaire d'une partie des aides aux
grandes cultures et vous parlais tout à
l'heure justement des zones végétales
des zones céréalières céréalière
l'accompagnement de la réorientation des
systèmes de production
l'engagement sur le développement
durable on l'a déjà vu dans le grenelle
1 on aura l'occasion de le revoir il ya
peut-être là effectivement des efforts
qui doivent être faits les décisions qui
vont être prises et qui seront annoncés
pour partie au début du mois d'avril
doit préfigurer de nouveaux modes de
soutien pour notre agriculture et ses
décisions en ga s'engage en fait sur la
voie d'une sortie progressive de
références historiques qui ne peuvent
plus être des références actuelles c'est
le statu quo qui serait la pire des
solutions
nous allons donc et le ministre de
l'agriculture s'est engagé avec vous
avec l'ensemble des acteurs essayer de
définir des politiques prioritaires pour
les zones justement intermédiaire
monsieur le président raincourt soyez en
tout cas assuré que le gouvernement rend
bien en considération la situation de
ces secteurs dont vous êtes
naturellement l'un des porte paroles les
plus émérites
merci monsieur le ministre par le canada
françoise laborde pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole mme asher colette
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je
souhaite interroger le gouvernement sur
sa politique économique et sociale dans
une situation de crise grave pour notre
pays nos territoires et tous les
français alors que les effets annoncés
du plan de relance se font toujours
attendre en particulier pour ceux de
plus en plus nombreux qui souffre d'une
forte diminution de leur pouvoir d'achat
vous vous refusez toujours à agir sur la
consommation
privilégiant le seul investissement
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à lire le
récent rapport du sénat rédigé par notre
collègue bernard angèle ce dans lequel
il fait la démonstration qu'une relance
direct par la consommation serait d'une
grande et rapide efficacité les faits et
les chiffres sont là les entreprises
licencient ajoutant la crise sociale à
la crise
industriels alors pourquoi persister
vous dans la mauvaise direction
avec mes collègues radicaux de gauche et
la majorité du groupe rdse
je partage les inquiétudes des français
qui s'exprime avec force aujourd'hui
dans tout le pays sur les conséquences
de la politique menée et en particulier
sur les orientations prises en matière
d'emploi et de pouvoir d'achat pour les
plus modestes
cette politique et les priorités
retenues enfonce chaque jour un peu plus
les français dans la précarité
l'appauvrissement et l'incertitude dans
le secteur hommes publics la mise en
oeuvre de la révision générale des
politiques publiques est synonyme de
révision drastique des emplois sur
l'ensemble du territoire y compris en
zone rurale et dans les quartiers
sensibles
je pense en particulier aux secteurs de
la santé de l'éducation de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche dans tous ces domaines
force est de constater que notre pays
régresse dans le secteur privé déjà
quatre cent mille chômeurs
supplémentaires sont annoncées pour 2009
les indicateurs sont au rouge
et les réponses du gouvernement sont
insuffisantes quand elles ne sont pas
inadaptée dans ces conditions combien de
temps faudra-t-il encore attention avant
que le gouvernement ne prenne la mesure
de la crise qui frappe les français
voilà les questions monsieur le
président quand allez vous cesser de
gérer la crise et enfin intervenir avec
force et détermination
quand allez vous préférez le bouclier
social à l'injuste et 6,1 décembre
bouclier fiscal
quand allez-vous agir sur le seul
véritable levier de relance qui soit la
consommation pour me répondre la parole
et à monsieur hervé novelli secrétaire
d'état chargé du commerce et de
l'artisanat et messieurs les sénateurs
madame le sénateur françoise laborde ne
partageons pas votre analyse et nous
avons l'histoire pour cela vous savez et
vous connaissez l'échec historique qui a
été
causés lors de la relance par la
consommation initiée par le président
mitterrand dans les années 80 cela a
entraîné un recentrage cela arrange
entraîné un recentrage de la politique
économique qui est bien connu dans les
manuels et qui fait et qui instruit sur
l'inanité d'une relance par la
consommation nous avons préféré la
relance par l'investissement en
choisissant un la réactivité dans un
plan dans un plan qui aujourd'hui est un
des plans les plus puissants de tous les
pays de l'union européenne
je vous rappelle quelques chiffres
madame le sénateur il ne faut pas les
oublier
cette crise elle n'est pas française et
vous avez tort de stigmatiser le
gouvernement je vous rappelle que vos
amis socialistes espagnols en sont
aujourd'hui
sur le seul mois de janvier à près de
350 mille chômeurs supplémentaires je
vous rappelle que vos amis travailliste
anglais traverse la crise une des crises
les plus profondes de leur histoire donc
cela ne sert à rien de pointer du doigt
les responsabilités de tel ou tel
gouvernement
nous avons été les parmi les plus
réactifs de l'union européenne
et lorsque vous dites que nous ne
faisons rien pour l'emploi je voudrais
vous rendre attentive au fait que les
moyens de la politique de l'emploi ont
été augmentés de près de 25% depuis le
début de la crise nous avons augmenté
les allocations de chômage partiel qui
sont passés de 60 à 75% du salaire brut
nous avons aidé les salariés qui ont
perdu leur emploi à rebondir par une
meilleure indemnisation ou les
formations sur lui nous renforcer et
troisième impératif soutenir l'emploi
c'est ce que nous faisons avec un
dispositif qui rend donc un grand succès
qui est le dispositif zéro charge dans
les très petites entreprises qui
bénéficient d'ores et déjà de 3000
embauches par jour voilà la réalité bien
éloignée de la description que vous
faites de la situation de notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre a parlé
maintenant monsieur roland courteau pour
le groupe socialiste il avait la parole
mon cher collègue si monsieur le
président des centaines de milliers
d'emplois sont menacés et supprimer dans
l'agroalimentaire la chimie l'automobile
la distribution et de nombreuses autres
industries continental total sony
pontonx ma mort est un autre et mes
collègues carrère et 20 hommes notamment
ne me démentiront pas certaines
entreprises qui ont perçu des fonds
publics se sont même délocalisé
l'exemple le plus frappant est totale
qui avaient 14 milliards de profits aux
annonces et plus de 500 suppressions
d'emplois un autre exemple et
continental qui a trompé les salariés en
leur promettant d investissement en
échange de sacrifices et qui maintenant
les envoie au chômage
le seul objectif de ces groupes et non
seulement le profit mais la distribution
des dividendes aux gros actionnaires et
le maintien des rémunérations
pharaoniques des dirigeants est tant pis
tant pis pour les salariés sacrifiés
face à un tel cynisme que fait le
gouvernement ils annoncent ils annoncent
ils parlent dans l'ombre la droite
il annonce qu'il sera exigeant guy
gilain la belle affaire monsieur sarkozy
annonce que l'on va passer à un nouveau
type de capitalisme et qu'il n'en avait
pas que les entreprises qui profitent de
la crise pour se restructurer et
supprimé des emplois en réalité rien ne
se passe la france a perdu 107 mille
emplois au dernier trimestre 2008 et
l'assurance chômage en hausse 400000
destructions d'emplois en 2009 mais le
gouvernement refuse de reconnaître ses
erreurs le bouclier fiscal qui le crée
aucun emploi qui nous coûtent des
milliards et qui permet aux riches
d'échapper à l'impôt sur leurs
dividendes
notez que le gouvernement se garde bien
de présenter un projet de loi qui
permettrait au comité d'entreprise de se
prononcer non pas sur le contenu d'un
plan social mais sur son utilité
économique et d'évaluer les dégâts
sociaux qu'il va créer vous négligez
surtout que des entreprises qui
bénéficient des exonérations de
cotisations sociales signent des accords
salariaux ou de maintien de l'emploi
or l'europe ne l'interdît pas quand
allez vous enfin réagir concrètement
contre les pratiques scandaleuses de ces
entreprises qui ont perçu des fonds
publics et qui engrangent des bénéfices
colossaux pour vous répondre la parole à
monsieur hervé novelli secrétaire d'état
chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce et de
l'artisanat vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur roland courteau
je partage l'exposer au début de votre
question à savoir que nous avons que
nous avons et c'est vrai comment
pourrait-on le nier une augmentation
aujourd'hui sensible des plans sociaux
dans notre pays et une hausse des
inscriptions au chômage pour
licenciements économiques
c'est la conséquence directe de la crise
mondiale qui se traduit par des plans
sociaux de grande ampleur et une
augmentation j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire par exemple du chômage en espagne
350 mille demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires au mois de janvier
vous dites que nous n'avons fait que
nous avons fait peu de choses
ce qui distingue notre pays d'autres
pays en europe monsieur le sénateur ce
sont les obligations fortes qui pèsent
sur les entreprises en matière de plans
sociaux
je voudrais vous rappeler parce que vous
semblez l'avoir oublié une entreprise de
plus de 1000 salariés qui procèdent à
des licenciements à des obligations
financières en termes de revitalisation
des territoires
quant à celles de moins de 1000 salariés
elles doivent proposer vous le savez à
leurs salariés des conventions de
reclassement personnalisé
mais nous ne nous contentons pas de bol
de veiller à la bonne application de ces
dispositions légales
nous faisons tout pour éviter au maximum
ces suppressions d'emplois en facilitant
le recours à l'activité partielle pour
les entreprises en difficulté
c'est nous et non pas vous qui avons
améliorer l'indemnisation du chômage
partiel qui est passé de 50 à 60% puis
75%
une est et cela je crois doit être
soulignée vous ne l'avez pas fait nous
avons aussi permis de rebondir par
l'extension à de nouveaux bassins du
contrat de transition professionnelle là
aussi vous ne nous avez pas parlé je le
regrette
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais aussi
vous indiquer que le gouvernement refuse
toute forme de fatalisme en matière
d'emploi mais il ne se livre pas une
sorte d'incantation comme vous le faites
en mettant sur le dos de telle ou telle
mesure
une crise qui est malheureusement
mondiale et que vous vous acharnez à
nier à dont vous vous acharnez à nier ce
caractère
vous avez tort vous avez tort car
lorsque nous sortirons de la crise
eh bien nous sortirons plus forts grâce
à nos mesures et non pas grâce à vos
incantations
merci merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
serge dassault pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
emilie chat collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur haut commissaire à
la jeunesse rappeler au préalable que le
nombre des jeunes sans emploi en france
est malheureusement beaucoup plus élevé
qu'ailleurs
pourquoi et bien parce que nos systèmes
de formation scolaire est totalement
inadapté aux motivations de certains de
nos jeunes qui souhaiteraient une
formation plus professionnelle que
théorique
le collège unique est un échec puisque
chaque année cent quarante piges jeunes
sortent du système scolaire sans aucune
formation professionnelle il devient des
chômeurs voir des délinquants alors que
de nombreux emplois professionnels sont
inoccupés
je crois que vous n'habitez pas à les
communes correspondant mes chers
collègues
la solution s'appelle apprentissage pour
former à des métiers et non passage
obligatoire par le bachot kenan le plus
souvent à aucun emploi mais ça concerne
plus autres l'éducation nationale
monsieur darcos qui se pend devrait
réfléchir à ce problème
si l'on veut développer l'apprentissage
il ferait aussi modifié donc notre
système de formation scolaire et faire
en sorte que les apprentis puissent
trouver une entreprise pour accueillir
ce qui est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui car c'est d'entreprise
depuis deux ans 50 salariés sont obligés
de prendre d'apprentis nil prévu il ya
un prévu pour les plus petites
alors monsieur lui je voudrais
simplement vous proposait d'abaisser ce
seuil à 50 salariés de façon à augmenter
le nombre d'entreprises pouvant
accueillir des apprentis et réduire
ainsi le chômage des jeunes
loin aussi ajouté que je me dise cas sur
les autres cas du travail oblige le chef
d'entreprise a demandé l'avis du médecin
du travail sont des machines tournantes
me l'a dit suda parties de moins 18 ans
et la plupart des chefs d'entreprises
pme tpe y renonce
devant le coût et les difficultés et
l'attention des huit ans même si le
travail surchargé
c'est pourquoi ils veulent plus prendre
d'apprentis de -18 ans l'obligation des
billets se d'abaisser ce seuil à 50 c
est que je vous propose devrait donc
être aussi a sorti une modification du
code du travail présentera les apprentis
de -18 ans car se moquent totalement la
formation merci monsieur pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur martin
hirsch haut commissaire aux solidarités
actives contre la pauvreté haut
commissaire à la jeunesse vous avez la
parole monsieur le haut commissaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur serge dassault nous connaissons
tous ici votre engagement en faveur de
l'emploi des jeunes notamment au niveau
local et je partage votre volonté de
soutenir le développement des formations
en alternance et notamment
l'apprentissage et le contrat de
professionnalisation
pourquoi tout simplement parce que on
sait que ça marche
l'alternance est un vrai passeport pour
l'emploi il est plébiscité par les
employeurs comme par les jeunes puisque
8 jeunes sur 10 qui s'engagent dans
cette voie trouve à la sortie un emploi
et vous avez raison de dire qu'il faut
en ce moment le soutenir
et lui donner de nouvelles conditions
parce qu'aujourd'hui en période de crise
on voit une réduction des processus
d'alternance liée à la crise et donc il
faut l'aider le développement de
l'apprentissage ces dernières années a
été favorisée par un ensemble de mesures
prises depuis 2005 et qui doivent
beaucoup au président larcher lorsqu'il
était ministre du travail et à jean
louis borloo crédit d'impôt de 1600
euros revalorisation du statut
d'empereur d'apprentis campagne de
promotion de l'apprentissage création
d'un fonds national de modernisation de
l'apprentissage qui d'ailleurs ont été
initiateur a prouvé je crois par
l'opposition et la majorité dans les
mêmes conditions et un quota de jeunes
en alternance de 3% dans les entreprises
de plus de 250 salariés
à défaut de quoi majoration de 0 1 % de
la taxe d'apprentissage
il faut aller plus loin et comment la
commission de concertation sur
l'autonomie des jeunes à un groupe
spécifique sur ce travail là en liaison
avec laurent wauquiez notamment alors la
proposition d'être plus exigeant pour
les entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
mérite d'être creusée pour ne pas
effectivement qu'elle se retourne contre
les petites entreprises
parce qu'il ya deux ou trois choses
qu'il faut regarder la première c'est
qu'on ne peut le faire que si on est
capable de bien prendre en compte la
réalité de l'effort d'apprentissage
aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de tout ou
rien on traite de la même façon une
entreprise qui fait 2 8% et notre presse
qui fait 0,2 pour cent qui à la surtaxe
toute la surtaxe donc il faut qu'on soit
capable de faire véritablement prendre
en compte l'effort de l'entreprise
il faut aussi prendre en compte la durée
la présence des jeunes dans l'entreprise
au cours de l'année il faut aussi
vérifier
alors monsieur le ministre que les
le quota d'apprentissage est bien
soutenu donc nous sommes d'accord pour
creuser ce point et pour regarder si une
opportunité on peut les descendre canto
une minute sur le seconde sur les
conditions de sécurité des jeunes de
moins de 18 ans par rapport aux machines
outils vous comprendre bien cons et
qu'on doit ne pas mettre en dessous les
contraintes de sécurité vis-à-vis de
jeunes face à des machines dangereuses
il ya des questions de responsabilité de
sécurité qui sont importantes on a
réussi à baisser les taux d'accidents du
travail et il ne faut pas les faire
repartir à la hausse
merci merci monsieur le haut commissaire
la parole est maintenant madame patricia
fils âgé pour le groupe socialiste nous
avez la parole
ma chère collègue monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du travail des
relations sociales et de la solidarité
et porte sur la grève difficultés du
fonctionnement du pôle emploi en effet
le pôle emploi issu de la fusion de
l'anpe et du réseau de l'assedic a été
créé pour être plus efficace et plus
réactif dans le service offert aux
demandeurs d'emploi mais force est de
constater qu'un an et demi après
l'annnonce de la fusion anpe unedic par
le chef de l'état le pôle emploi est
inefficace et même inopérant face à une
augmentation importante du taux de
chômage
les chômeurs sont confrontés au
téléphone saturé au retard dans le
traitement des dossiers aux délais qui
s'allongent pour décrocher un premier
rendez vous et les appels sont surtaxés
68000 dossiers d'indemnisation de
demandeurs d'emploi sont en retard de
traitement au sein des services du pôle
emploi et alors que le chômage explose
le gouvernement reste de marbre
avec 250 mille demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires en quatre mois
le pôle emploi doit faire face à un raz
de marée sans précédent tous les exports
experts prévoient que le taux de chômage
dépassera de la barre des 10 % début
2010 voire même d'ici la fin de l'année
autre signal inquiétant la progression
rapide de 0,6 point sur un an
messes du taux de chômage des 25 49 ans
en outre on observe une augmentation du
chômage des personnes qualifiées et
diplômées entre 40 et 50 ans il est
certain que l'afflux des chômeurs va
provoquer une tension encore plus forte
sur le pôle emploi en effet les quarante
cinq mille agents du pôle emploi sont
déjà en surcharge de travail et dans le
même temps ils doivent se former dans
leur nouveau rôle
aujourd'hui le pôle emploi à un
conseiller pour environ 120 ch au mr on
est de long loin de l'objectif qui
pourrait avoir un conseiller pour 60
chômeurs la fusion n'a pas été
suffisamment anticipé et l'institution
madame monsieur nos tournées justifie
pas tous les problèmes et de
dysfonctionnements internes mot nouvel
organisme l'insuffisance du nombre
d'agents dont dispose paul emploi et y
intolérable l'inscription
l'indemnisation et l'accompagnement des
chômeurs sont les missions que devraient
offrir le pôle emploi on est bien loin
il faut prendre des mesures d'urgence
pour augmenter les effectifs face à la
dégradation des conditions de travail du
service
monsieur le ministre la situation
s'aggrave et le gouvernement la porte de
réponse adaptée les mesures prises par
le gouvernement sont inefficaces alors
que le gouvernement devrait tout mettre
en oeuvre pour faciliter la recherche
d'emploi
dans un contexte aussi difficile ils
étaient vos relations pose ici un grand
service public de l'emploi moderne et
performant capable d'orienter les
demandeurs d'emploi et leur devenir un
interlocuteur monsieur le ministre non
la question est la suivante quelles sont
les mesures d'urgence que le
gouvernement entend prendre pour pallier
ces dysfonctionnements
pour vous répondre deux minutes par
l'état monsieur hervé novelli secrétaire
d'état chargé du commerce ésident la
parole monsieur le ministre sur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice sillinger
la mise en oeuvre de pôle emploi je vous
le rappelle elle est effective depuis le
1er janvier
l'annoncé a été faite auparavant mais
c'est une réalité que la création du
pôle emploi nous ouf
nous offrons désormais aux demandeurs
d'emploi un seul interlocuteur pour le
placement et l'indemnisation un seul
système dead
un accompagnement renforcé grâce à la
mutualisation des moyens
j'ajoute que il a été confiée à pôle
emploi la gestion du dispositif zéro
charge pour toutes les embauches dans
les très petites entreprises en 2009
l'ensemble de ces simplifications
apportées seront mises en place d'ici
septembre
100% de guichet unique à l'été la
généralisation de l'entretien unique et
des référents uniques
à la rentrée il ne s'agit pas de nier
les difficultés
lorsqu'on a une telle nouveauté dans le
paysage social français
bien sûr cela ne se fait pas aussi
facilement que cela le gouvernement a
conscience des tensions fortes que cela
entraîne et de la surcharge de travail
que cela représente pour les quarante
cinq mille agents de pôle emploi dont
nous souhaitons ici ne pas critiquer
l'action et je voudrais saluer le
travail exemplaire et bien afin de faire
face à l'augmentation du nombre des
dossiers pôle emploi la demande du
gouvernement a procédé à des
recrutements en cdd et mobilisé ses
agents y compris le samedi
résultat le nombre de dossiers en
attente dont vous faites état
madame le sénateur est retombé
aujourd'hui je souhaitais vous
l'apprendre vous ne semblez pas le
savoir à 58 milles ce qui est le niveau
normal ce qui est le niveau normal il
n'y a pas je tiens à le souligner de
retard
aucun retard en matière de versement de
l'indemnisation chômage ce qui me semble
naturel est important par ailleurs le
gouvernement étudie aujourd'hui la
demande d'un renfort des effectifs de
pôle emploi permettant ainsi de garantir
aux demandeurs d'emploi un
accompagnement adapté vous avez parlé
des difficultés du 39 49
le numéro d'appel unique et c'est vrai
que le nombre très élevé d'appels reçus
plus d'un million à entraîner des
difficultés ne s'agit pas de le nier et
nous ne le nions pas nous avons fait en
sorte d'y apporter les réponses
techniques nécessaires je voulais vous
indiquer que le taux d'aboutissement des
appels est désormais de plus de 70% avec
toutefois des disparités régionales
encore importante nous couper à
améliorer très rapidement ce résultat
mais madame le sénateur
cette réforme qui consistait à trouve à
créer un
interlocuteur unique cela faisait plus
de vingt ans qu'elle était demandé il y
a d'un côté le ministère de la parole et
de l'autre le ministère de l'action nous
l'avons fait la parole est maintenant
monsieur pierre hérisson qui voudra bien
poser ces questions bioéthiques pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre ma question
s'adresse à monsieur andré santini
secrétaire d'état à la fonction publique
et auparavant excusez mon audace
monsieur le président je voudrais
remettre mon badge des jeux la
candidature des jeux olympiques d'hiver
annecy à monsieur laporte
merci beaucoup monsieur président chez
le ministre
l'article 48 de la loi du 2 février 2007
de modernisation de la fonction publique
a ouvert aux fonctionnaires de la poste
la possibilité d'être intégré dans le
corps ou cadre d'emplois de la fonction
publique de l'état de la fonction
publique territoriale ou de la fonction
publique hospitalière
cette disposition a toutefois limité
dans le temps
ce dispositif spécial de mobilité entre
les fonctions publiques en fixant date
butoir au 31 décembre 2009
cette date avait été retenu par
référence à celles fixées par l'article
5 de la loi du 31 décembre de 2003 qui
ouvrait les mêmes possibilités pour les
fonctionnaires de france télécom
toutefois une des principales
caractéristiques de ce dispositif tient
au fait que la demande de l'agent pour
intégrer le corps d'accueil choisi ne
peut se concrétiser qu'à l'issue d'une
période d'une année comprenant quatre
mois de mise à disposition en guise de
stage probatoire et ensuite lui - de
détachement or l'article 29 5 précités
dispose que les fonctionnaires de la
poste peuvent être intégrés dans leurs
demandes
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2009
cependant dans ces conditions les
fonctionnaires de la poste désireux de
s'engager dans ce dispositif ne peuvent
plus le faire depuis le 31 décembre 2008
aussi monsieur le ministre que puis je
répondre à mon postiers au sein voyeur
qui est un projet professionnel dans la
fonction publique territoriale et qui
s'inquiète de savoir s'il pourra
bénéficier en 2009
comme ses collègues l'an passé du
dispositif de détachement dérogatoire
facilitant sa mobilité vers une autre
fonction publique
ma question monsieur le ministre est la
suivante le dispositif de détachement
dérogatoire de la poste est il
effectivement opérationnel en 2009 et
envisagez vous de le proroger
je vous remercie de la réponse messi
thierry sueur pour vous répondre la
parole est à monsieur andré santini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la fonction
publique
donner la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs sur le sénateur hérisson
merci de me ne pas me questionner sur le
bouclier fiscal je pense que la leçon a
porté vous êtes tous maintenant
parfaitement au courant
comme vous venez de le rappeler aux
jeunes sénateurs la loi de modernisation
de la fonction publique du 2 février
2007 a ouvert aux fonctionnaires de la
poste la possibilité d'être intégré dans
la fonction publique de l'état dans la
fonction publique territoriale ou dans
la fonction publique hospitalière
à l'instar d'ailleurs de ce qui a été
fait pour france télécom vous soulignez
une difficulté réelle dans l'application
du dispositif qui est plus
opérationnelle depuis le 31 décembre
je vous confiant que le gouvernement
souhaite permettre aux fonctionnaires de
la poste qui le demande d'entrer dans ce
dispositif jusqu'au 31 décembre 2012
afin d'aligner sa durée totale sur la
durée du dispositif dont a bénéficié
france télécom
il nous faut pour cela le prolonger par
rapport aux dispositions actuelles eric
woerth et moi même avons écrit en ce
sens à jean paul bailly président de la
poste le 27 octobre dernier pour
formaliser cet engagement nous allons
aussi écrire à jean courtial conseiller
d'état président de la commission de
classement de la poste commission
administrative placée sous l'autorité du
ministère de l'économie de l'industrie
et de l'emploi pour lui indiquer que le
gouvernement prendrait qu en 2009 la
dispositions législatives nécessaires
pour proroger le dispositif
il est en effet indispensable que la
commission en charge puisse continuer
d'instruire les dossiers afin que les
fonctionnaires de la poste qui
souhaiteraient revenir vers la fonction
publique ne soient pas pénalisés comme
le postier haut-savoyard auquel vous
faites référence en attente d'un
véhicule législatif approprié et que je
tiens grâce à vous à saluer
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant à monsieur philippe anneaux
pour la réunion administrative des
sénateurs d'un figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
vous avez la parole monsieur le sénateur
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question sada s'adresse à madame
pécresse ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche et porte
sur la concrétisation des garanties
données aux instituts universitaires de
technologie relativement à leurs moyens
de fonctionnement
quand nous avons réfléchi à la révision
du mode de calcul des dotations
budgétaires attribuée par l'état aux
universités
nous avons affiché l'ambition d'une plus
grande équité et d'une efficacité accrue
de l'utilisation des moyens notre
rapport rendu en juin dernier au nom de
la commission des finances et de la
commission des affaires culturelles avec
mon collègue jean léonce dupont avait
préconisé une enveloppe financière
globale allouée par leurs universités
permettant aux iut de mettre en oeuvre
leur projet je sais madame la ministre
l'action déterminante qui est la vôtre
pour prendre en compte nos
recommandations
mais j'aimerais savoir à ce jour où vous
en êtes des garanties promises par le
gouvernement
je pense par exemple au pourcentage des
modes de financement reposant sur la
performance et notamment sur l'insertion
professionnelle je songe aussi à la
prise en compte du coût plus élevé de la
formation dans les iut
je vous remercie madame la ministre de
nous donner des réponses susceptibles de
conforter les directeurs d'iut et les
étudiants qui je le rappelle joue un
rôle majeur dans notre système contenu
de leur réussite dans la
professionnalisation et ainsi de les
rassurer sur la pérennité du financement
pour vous répondre là par les vallées
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
vous avez la parole mme la ministre
ainsi monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur philippe adnot les instituts
universitaires de technologie sont l'un
des piliers de notre système
d'enseignement supérieur et c'est l'une
des filières de réussite de notre
système
il dispense une formation de qualité de
proximité
il participe à la dynamique de chacun de
nos territoires et ils ont des résultats
impressionnants en matière d'insertion
professionnelle
alors cette réussite elle doit être
préservé ça veut dire que les
universités autonomes doivent tenir
compte des spécificités des iut
c'est pour cela que j'ai souhaité que
les présidents d'université des
directeurs d'iut signent une charte pour
mettre en oeuvre leurs bonnes relations
futures pour donner toute sa valeur et
toute sa force à cette charte
je vais lui conférer une valeur
réglementaire et elle sera adressée dès
demain à tous les présidents
d'université et à tous les directeurs
d'iut
il faut que les iut et les moyens de
s'épanouir dans le cadre d université
autonome les moyens évidemment financier
et humain
ils les auront il y aura un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens qui va être
négocié entre le président de
l'université le directeur de l'iut et
qui sera transmis en juin à mon
ministère
d'ores et déjà tous les présidents
d'université se sont engagés pour 2009
mais aussi pour 2010 à maintenir à
minima les moyens actuels de chacun de
leurs iut
quant à l'état il a accordé vous le
savez 5 millions d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires aux iut cette année pour
améliorer l'accueil des bacheliers
technologiques dans les iut et faire
fonctionner l'ascenseur social
ces 5 millions d'euros seront reconduits
en 2009 et enfin dans le cadre du plan
de relance
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer que 10
millions d'euros iront spécifiquement à
l'équipement des iut
enfin les iut seront associés à la
réflexion sur le modèle d'allocation des
moyens que vous avez mentionné monsieur
sénateurs alors cher philippe adnot les
iut compte pour vous sachez qu'il compte
aussi pour nous merci madame la ministre
chers collègues nous en avons maintenant
fini avec les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance quelques
instants elle sera aux prises dans
quelques minutes pour la communication
de monsieur jean paul delevoye médiateur
de la république sur son rappel sur son
rapport annuel
la séance est donc suspendu voilà vous
venez donc de suivre en direct dans
l'hémicycle ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
comme vous l'avez vu effectivement les
thèmes autour de la crise économique et
sociale la grande manifestation
aujourd'hui les questions autour du
bouclier fiscal est bien toutes ces
questions ont prédominé aujourd'hui lors
de cette séance aux questions des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement on
va revenir sur ces différents thèmes
cet après midi avec nos invités les
sénateurs les ministres concernés même
si vous avez vu aujourd'hui l'hémicycle
était vite c'était aussi la grève un peu
sur les bancs à la fois dessinateur mais
également du gouvernement peu de
ministres pour répondre aux questions
c'est une des sénateurs peu de sénateur
également pour interpeller le
gouvernement notamment les rangs de la
gauche était clair très clairsemé les
sénateurs communistes et socialistes
on sent bien sûr aux côtés des salariés
et des syndicats pour défiler
aujourd'hui dans les rues des
différentes villes de france on va
commencer cette deuxième séance de
questions d'actualité avec les ministres
et les sénateurs en parlons de sports
bernard laporte le secrétaire d'état
chargé des sports nous rejoint bonjour
merci
de répondre à nos questions on va bien
sûr revenir sur la ville d'annecy
désigné y est
hier comme candidate de la commune
candidate de la france pour les jeux
d'hiver en 2018
oui effectivement c'est ainsi qu'il ya
gagné donc ces primaires puisque il y
avait quatre belles candidatures et moi
j'ai une pensée pour pour la ville de
nice de grenoble et de pelvoux écrins
parce que leur dossier qui m'ont été
présentés
un mois avant cette élection était
vraiment des dossiers de qualité
alors qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
et il fallait à nommer un don il y avait
un critère de sélection bon mais les
gens ont décidé que c'était en dessous
vient de me remettre ainsi parce que à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est la
candidature de la france n 6 qui a gagné
donc il faut se mobiliser se rassembler
derrière cette candidature est allé
jouer le match le plus important face à
munich face au coréen donc encore une
fois on aura besoin de beaucoup de
solidarité
voilà on voit effectivement vous avez le
petit pin ce qui vous a été remis par le
sénateur du département de la haute
savoie ce petit pin zahlé le porter tous
les jours c'est quand la décision finale
non là il ya deux étapes donc il y a
mi 2010 et la décision définitive se
fera à durban en juillet 2011 et il ya
d'abord une seconde à peine le short
list donc est ce qu'on va y être
en juillet 2010 donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être très performant et ensuite si
on est dans la short list il restera
énorme pour essayer de l'emporter donc
en juillet 2011
est-ce qu'il ya encore de la neige en
2018 c'est la grande question on verra
t-on vous êtes avec nous bernard laporte
une question sur la défaite de la france
en rugby face à l'angleterre dimanche
dernier très très lourde défaite et déjà
des voix s'élèvent pour réclamer la
démission de marc lièvremont que vous
dites quoi vous jeudi que marc les
romands ne jouais pas ce jour là j'ai
encore une fois je crois qu'il l'a dit
lui-même un entraîneur ça prenne ses
responsabilités la défaite est là on la
subit moi j'étais entrepreneurs pendant
huit ans l'équipe de france quand on
perd on perd des joueurs quand on gagne
on gagne avec eux mais que je crois que
c'est un une défaillance collective ce
jour là effectivement les choses ne sont
pas rentrés dans le match
bon on n'est jamais content que l'équipe
de france est battue aussi sévèrement
qui plus est par les anglais mais bon
ils ont même match pour se rattraper ces
samedi à rome face à l'italie ce sera
pas un match facile et c'est jamais
facile de jouer contre les italiens mais
si la france est quand même supérieur
mais il faut quand même encore une fois
livré le match les italiens auront à
coeur de gagner un match qu'ils n'ont
pas gagné pour le moment
donc ça naît ça s'annonce matchs est
difficile pour l'équipe de france mais
c'est l'occasion rêvée pour générer
retrouver un certain élan certain
dynamisme une certaine détermination
voilà donc nous irons les accompagner à
rome samedi nous pousserons très fort
parce que on n'aime pas voir l'équipe de
france je subis on n'aime pas voir
l'équipe de france que ce soit de rugby
de football ou d'autres d'ailleurs ne
pas voir douze équipes de france perdue
allez merci beaucoup
bernard laporte et on soutient tous
effectivement la candidature d'annecy on
va parler maintenant crise économique
financière sociale avec jean arthuis
sion voilà jean arthuis le président de
la commission des finances du sénat qui
est avec nous monsieur arty bonjour
bonjour
beaucoup de français sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui c'est une journée de
manifestations sociales
est-ce qu'il peut tjrs à voir est ce que
selon vous le gouvernement peut ou doit
lâcher du lest sur le plan des aides
qu'il peut apporter aux français en
difficulté je crois que dans
dans les marges de manoeuvre si tant est
qu'on puisse parler de marge de
manoeuvre
le gouvernement est allé jusqu'au bout
de ce qu'il pouvait faire
oserai-je dire que avant même le premier
plan de relance notre déficit
prévisionnel près de 60 milliards plus
ce déficit de la sécurité sociale était
déjà à eux seuls ces deux déficit
prévisionnel était déjà des plans de
relance en tout cas des plans de soutien
à la consommation et là maintenant on va
être à plus de 100 milliards de déficit
4 milliards et on le vérifiera dans le
collectif budgétaire auquel il faut
ajouter probablement une quinzaine au
moins 2 milliards de sécurité sociale ça
veut dire 120 milliards ça mais alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya pas
de réponse c'est à dire qu'il faut dire
aux gens dans la rue qu'on ne peut rien
faire aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu' il
faut faire jouer tous les instruments de
solidarité ils sont à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui j'entends dire qu'il
faudrait va être des milliards
supplémentaires en consommation mais
est-ce cela qui va redonner du vrai
pouvoir d'achat c'est à dire de
l'activité économique
les autres réformes que nous avons
affaire sont celles qui contribuent à
redonner de la compétitivité aux travail
aux entreprises et aux territoires
alors il y à un débat fiscal à droite
notamment justement sur la solidarité
sur la contribution de ceux qui ont le
plus de revenus
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
d'ailleurs ça a été vraiment beaucoup
abordé dans ses questions d'actualité
aujourd'hui faire quelque chose sur ce
fameux bouclier fiscal ou trouver en
tout cas une manière de faire contribuer
ceux qui gagnent le plus davantage à la
solidarité nationale
on voit bien que le bouclier fiscal est
un bel instrument lorsqu'on est sûre
d'aller vers une baisse générale des
impôts
lorsque malheureusement il faut
augmenter un impôt et on l'a vérifié à
l'occasion du financement de la
généralisation du revenu de solidarité
active
ce bouclier fiscal revient comme un
boomerang politique parce que parce que
c'est une sorte de sauf-conduit fiscale
pour tous ceux qui ont un certain
aérosols paix ceux qui sont en dessous
du bouclier fiscal
et puis on voit bien comment s'applique
le bouclier fiscal il s'implique pas sur
le revenu de référence il s'implique sur
le revenu après qu'on ai déduit un
certain nombre de défiscalisation alors
qu'est ce que vous proposez
et bien moi je propose que l'on la
broche le bouclier fiscal je propose que
l'on remplace lisf par une tranche
supplémentaire d'impôt sur le revenu
châtie bien qu'on remplace et ainsi on
contribuera à l'équilibré des finances
publiques on simplifiera notre fiscalité
car aujourd'hui elle est d'une telle
complexité qu'elle se prête à toutes les
opérations d'optimisation la fiscalité
est au coeur du pacte républicain
le l'idée que nous nous faisons de la
justice elle doit être simple lisible
compréhensible et équitable merci merci
jean arthuis président de la commission
des finances du sénat d'être venu en
direct à notre micro au pérenno
oui et hervé nommé 9 et 10 bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors que les
manifestations sont nombreuses elles
sont importantes aujourd'hui un peu
partout dans les villes de france
qu'est ce que vous dites aux salariés
qui manifestent aujourd'hui mais peut il
ya une inquiétude qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui dans la rue me semble
légitime
nous sommes dans une situation d'une
crise économique très brutal très rude
qui affecte tous les pays et la france
comme tous les autres je remarque que
les dans un certain nombre de pays la
situation est encore plus grave que chez
nous en espagne en a détruit 350 mille
emplois et il y a aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre de pays une crise qui est
encore plus profonde
en angleterre on le sait la situation
est encore plus grave
le gouvernement est à la manoeuvre il a
il tentait et je crois qu'il fait montre
de la meilleure réactivité possible
les français disent aujourd'hui ça ne
suffit pas alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire de plus mais les français ils ont
raisons de penser que ça ne suffit pas
puisque la situation est difficile mais
on ne saurait s'en sortira pas d'un coup
de baguette magique
tous les pays sont frappés ce qui est
important dans cette période c'est à la
fois d'être très réactif ce qu'est le
gouvernement je le crois et aussi de
préparer l'avenir
c'est l'objet de toutes les réformes
profondes structurelles j'ai eu
l'occasion la de répondre à une question
sur la création du pôle emploi à cette
fusion qui était demandée depuis 20 ans
entre les et les assedic c'est fait il y
a beaucoup de réformes qui prépare
l'après crise mais pour l'instant la
situation difficile implique que nous
soyons mobilisés tous et que l'on ne se
perdent pas en querelles politiciennes
inutile ce dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui c'est d'action très
puissante plan de relance en est à est
l'une d'entre elles
nous avons besoin aussi de préparer
l'avenir ce que nous faisons nous avons
besoin enfin de cohésion nationale et
c'est à cela que j'appelle est en charge
au gouvernement d entreprise
laurence parisot la patronne du medef
est très critique et très attaqué cette
semaine à ce que les fragiliser je ne
sais pas je suis en charge des
entreprises pas des organisations
patronales ce que je constate c'est que
nous avons une action d'accompagnement
notamment pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont aujourd'hui
certainement les éléments les plus
fragiles dans la chaîne économique il
faut assurer leur financement
il faut éviter que par des attitudes
trop frileuse elle soit contrainte à des
dépôts de bilan c'est ce que nous
faisons tous les jours avec la médiation
du crédit avec les comités
départementaux de financement il y a
aujourd'hui quelques comportements
condamnables d'une brutalité en matière
de restructuration qui n'est pas
acceptable
mais pour tout le reste les chefs
d'entreprise doivent être encouragés et
non pas vilipender ce sont eux qui
détiennent les ressorts de la croissance
économique avec leurs salariés et il
faut donc leur faire confiance
très bien merci beaucoup et hervé
novelli henri de raincourt le président
du groupe ump voilà qui s'impatientait
derrière vous et qui va venir lui aussi
nous livrer son sentiment sur les grèves
les manifestations d'aujourd'hui est la
façon la meilleure de répondre à cette
inquiétude des salariés des manifestants
aujourd'hui en france la grève
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas à proprement
parler une surprise puisqu'elle fait
partie d'un plan qui a été annoncé par
les organisations syndicales depuis de
nombreuses semaines
donc les choses se déroulent sereinement
je crois est tout à fait normal que
celles et ceux qui veulent exprimer un
sentiment par rapport à la dureté de la
crise puissent le faire et par
conséquent je pense que tous les élus de
quelques sensibilités qu'il se réclame
sont très attentifs aux messages qui
sont portées par les grévistes attendent
ces grévistes attendent des réponses
claires concrètes donc même question
qu'à hervé novelli que le doit faire le
gouvernement dans les prochains jours
les prochaines semaines le gouvernement
a répondu par un sommet social le 18
février qui a décidé d'un certain nombre
de mesures concrètes qui sont d'ailleurs
actuellement en discussion à l'assemblée
nationale qui vont arriver au sénat très
prochainement et qui permettront de
mettre en oeuvre des mesures aussi
symbolique que pour les familles qui ont
les revenus les plus modestes et bien de
supprimer les deux tiers d'impôt qu'il
reste à payer d'accorder une prime de
200 euros
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes de
d'accorder des aides vos pots personnes
qui ont des enfants qui ont des
personnes handicapées voire des
personnes âgées dépendantes
donc tout ceci fait partie d'un plan
social qui a été arrêté par le
gouvernement en présence des
organisations syndicales
alors on ne peut pas malgré tout tous
les quinze jours
rajouter des dépenses à la dépense alors
que d'une part nous sommes dans une
situation de nos finances publiques qui
ne le permet pas et d'autre part nous
avons fait un choix stratégique pour
nous la meilleure protection
et le meilleur avenir possible pour le
développement du pouvoir d'achat c'est
l'emploi justement il ya un débat qui
agite la majorité en ce moment autour du
bouclier fiscal pour dégager peut-être
des marges de manoeuvre budgétaires de
l'argent est ce qu'il faut supprimer ou
non revenir sur le bouclier fiscal en
arguant notamment du fait que 2009 n'ait
pas 2008 n'est pas 2007 et que cette
période réclament plus de solidarité
ce qui est certain c'est qu'une
politique fiscale ne peut pas être
modifiée en permanence donc nous nous
avons fait le choix je le répète à la
période est très particulière non ça
fait rien on n'est pas là pour augmenter
les impôts parce que s'il faut se
comparer avec ne serait-ce que les pays
de l'union européenne
nous sommes le pays qui a le plus fort
taux de prélèvement de la richesse 42%
nous sommes le seul pays en europe qui
allie sf
donc il faut regarder si on veut que les
gens qui entreprennent qui réussissent
fui la france est bien continuons à
augmenter les impôts à les décourager et
ainsi qui est sûre qui retomberont les
conséquences comme d'habitude sur les
classes moyennes
donc c'est vraiment pas le choix tout ce
qu'on nous propose en ce moment c'est
j'allais dire un choix de la démagogie
mais c'est par mauvais message aussi
adressé aux français qui manifestent
aujourd'hui lorsqu'ils entendent que 834
contribuables ont touché des chèques à
hauteur de 360 milles 380 mille euros ça
les choque ça les français est bien
quand on est dans une période de crise
comme aujourd'hui il vaut mieux se
rassembler ses forces
plutôt que de passer son temps à monter
les français les uns contre les autres
c'est une espèce de maladies gauloise
qui est chez nous ancré depuis des
générations et des générations et qui
n'apportent jamais rien de positif
merci beaucoup henri de raincourt
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions tout de suite avec vous et
emmanuel un autre parlementaire lui
absolument nous accueillons le président
du conseil général du doubs sénateur
socialiste claude jeannerot bonjour et
merci d'être d'être avec nous tout
d'abord je sais que vous avez pris un
petit peu la température même si vous
êtes là aujourd'hui lors de cette
question séance des questions
d'actualité de ce qui se passe à
besançon sur la mobilisation sociale
qu'elle est
la situation actuellement nous le
disions j'étais un peu partagé j'aurais
aimé être présent aux côtés de mes
concitoyens pour manifester je me suis
inquiété de savoir si cette
manifestation était une réussite
à l'évidence les manifestants sont
nombreux ceux qui ce traduit j'ai
l'occasion de l'exprimer au premier
ministre s'agissant de la manifestation
du 29 janvier
je crois que nos concitoyens non
seulement en manifestant aussi nombreux
ressens une profonde inquiétude mais
surtout il apporte un désaveu par
rapport à la politique aujourd'hui
conduite par ce gouvernement
et c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle j'ai aussi tenu à rester auprès
de mes collègues au sénat aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir interpeller le gouvernement
sur sa politique fiscale en particulier
qui est très injuste dans un moment où
le pays va aussi mal alors justement
dans un département comme le vôtre le
doubs il ya notamment la crise de
l'automobile qui a un impact économique
assez fort
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous ressentez
cantat au tissu économique local et nous
sommes effectivement dans une difficulté
grave le département du doubs
mais c'est vrai aussi pour toute la
région franche comté et la région qui
connaît la plus forte dégradation de la
situation d'emploi ont plus 25 % de
chômage en un an
cellier naturellement à son caractère
industriel et tout particulièrement au
secteur de l'automobile qui irrigue une
très grande partie de notre territoire
et force est de reconnaître et
avant-hier nous avions le président de
la république dans notre département
j'aurais aimé pouvoir le lui exprimer
nous n'avons pas eu l'occasion mais
force est de reconnaître que
paradoxalement la franche comté et la
région qui a été la moins bien traitées
par le plan de relance
or nous manquons pas de projet que ce
soit d'infrastructures routières à
réaliser
ferroviaire a terminé parce que soutient
la ligne à grande vitesse justement
c'était un sujet qui est intervenu
nicolas sarkozy quand il est venu oui
alors je dois dire quand même qu'il a
fait une annonce il me faut être nuancée
il nous a promis que la branche est du
tgv serait achevée et effectivement nous
en avons besoin et c'est de la relance
ça c'est de la relance et nous le
réclamions et nous nous étonnions
d'ailleurs qu'il ne soit pas ce projet
dans le plan de relance et cette région
faut bien le reconnaître et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire au gouvernement a
connu de grands retards en matière
d'infrastructures nous avons aujourd'hui
des projets qui sont prêts à être
développé mis en oeuvre et il y a besoin
pour nous que la relance par
l'investissement soit plus effectif plus
importante
un tout dernier mot la place du
département aujourd'hui elle fait débat
ici même au sénat ya eu un débat hier
sur les collectivités territoriales et
la commission balladur
comment les choses son ressenti sur le
terrain à besançon dans le doubs écouter
j ai participé hier à ce débat et en
même temps je suis un peu juge et partie
bien sûr mais j'ai le sentiment que le
département ait reconnu précisément dans
un rôle très important nous l'évoquions
alès à l'instant sur son rôle de
solidarité territoriale
nous sommes dans un département de 594
commune des communes très dispersé et
nous pouvons grâce à cette clause de
compétence générale qui nous est un peu
disputées or grâce à cette clause la qui
veut dire que le département au fond pas
s'occuper d'un peu tout il peut
s'occuper un peu de tout mais
précisément c'est ça lui donne une
capacité d'initiative à pouvoir
intervenir en accompagnement des
communes sur des projets structurants
qui permettent d'aménager le territoire
qui permettent de créer les richesses de
demain et qui permettent au bout du
conte de réaliser cet équilibre rural
urbain qui est très important pour nos
territoires
voilà donc vous dites vous du terrain en
tout cas le département semble avoir
encore d'ardents défenseurs perrine oui
françois marc sénateur socialiste membre
de la commission des finances du sénat
est avec nous françois marc
on va revenir bien sûr sur les
manifestations d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que vous au parti socialiste doit tenter
notamment de l'intervention ce soir au
20 heures de tf1 du premier ministre
françois fillon
je pense que la première chose c'est que
le premier ministre dise qu'il a
clairement conscience de la situation
aujourd'hui vécu par les gens parce que
les gens le sentiment qu'on ne les
comprend pas ils ont le sentiment qu'on
on n'a pas vraiment conscience de l'état
de désarroi dans lequel se trouve
aujourd'hui beaucoup de familles et
beaucoup de salariés que vous constatez
vous dans votre département
oui c'est à dire que beaucoup de gens
viennent nous dire mais on comprend pas
très bien on est très inquiet on nous
dit pas vraiment ce qui se passe et on
voit tant d'informations aujourd'hui
désagréable sur des des centaines de
licenciements dans des pme ou dans des
entreprises importantes que on a
conscience qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde
peut être visé par ces plans de
licenciements donc c'est une inquiétude
profonde et puis il ya la deuxième
source d'inquiétude qui est la question
financière parce que tours ne voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui un déficit de 104
milliards d'euros sur le budget 2009 qui
n'est pour l'instant qu'une prévision
qui risque d'être encore alourdi ça
devra un jour m'a donné lieu à le
paiement d'une d'un impôt supplémentaire
ou d'une redevance ou de taxes et donc
aussi cette inquiétude qui entraîne
phénomène n'épargne donc c'est la
consommation ne se relance pas c'est
aussi parce que cette inquiétude est
bien présent dans l'esprit des gens on
n'évitera pas une hausse d'impôt vous le
dites et bien sûr le parti salissent
relance lui aussi le débat autour du
bouclier fiscal dont vous demander
l'abrogation mans mais le bouclier
fiscal c'est une goutte d'eau sur ces
100 milliards de déficit
le bouclier fiscal c'est un symbole je
crois que c'est ça qu'il faut retenir
c'est que quand on rembourse à des gens
qui sont très aisée puisqu'il s'agit
principalement de gens qui ont plus de
15 millions d'euros patrimoine une
partie de l'impôt qu'ils avaient payé et
ceci avec les contributions des plus
modestes puissent comprend dans l'argent
qui a été récolté ou plus auprès des
plus modestes pour rembourser par chèque
à quelques centaines de privilégiés
donc c'est symbolique c'est à dire que
les gens ont le sentiment que le régime
sarkozy et et boucler fiscal mis en
place il y a deux ans est aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
contestable et qui tend à favoriser une
très petite partie de la société et les
gens les plus aisés
donc c'est très symbolique alors bien
sûr et brooke socialiste au sénat va
déposer une proposition de loi pour
demander l'abrogation du bouclier fiscal
alors les socialistes demandent
l'abrogation j'ai demandé aujourd'hui
dans ma question au gouvernement
nous allons bien sûr voter la
proposition de loi qui est déposée par
le groupe communiste qui sera examiné le
26 mars
allant dans ce sens et nous allons aussi
déposé un abonnement que nous avons
appelée amendement obama qui consiste à
taxer les revenus les plus élevés c'est
à dire les revenus de plus de 380 mille
euros nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui
dans ce contexte difficile on ne peut
pas dire on va tous renvoyés à nos
enfants parce que quand on dit on
n'augmente pas les impôts ça veut dire
qu'on augmente la dette et la dette
augmente considérablement et la dette il
faudra la rembourser un jour ce sont nos
enfants qui vont être mis à contribution
donc nous nous disons il faut pas tout
renvoyer à nos enfants il faut donc
aujourd'hui mieux partager le gâteau et
donc par la fiscalité aujourd'hui
solliciter ceux qui sont en capacité de
payer
les américains et les anglais s'engage
dans cette voie
nous pensons qu'en france aussi on peut
demander un effort supplémentaire ceux
qui en ont la capacité et dès à présent
au moins annulé ce bouquet fiscale qui
est vraiment du point de vue symbolique
très très mal ressenti par l'opinion
publique en france
à bien écouter merci françois marc
dossier à suivre donc
merci d'avoir suivi en direct ce peu
plus que celle à ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
on fait le point sur notre antenne ce
soir à 18 heures et bien sûr cette
journée de manifestations ce sera
l'édition de 18 heures présenté par
michel grossiord et sonia mabrouk avec
de nombreux invités bien sûr pour réagir
à cette journée de manifestations
rendez vous à 18h